[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast uh
if you'd take a second and hit subscribe
that really helps with the algorithms
and helps with support of the channel so
that we can get amazing guests like we
have today Neil degrass Tyson he is an
astrophysicist and director of the
Hayden planetarium at New York's
American Museum of Natural History he
has also received 21 honorary doctorates
as well as NASA's distinguished public
service medal okay whatever everybody
knows who Neil degrass Tyson is he is
the
most funny charismatic smart cool nerdy
scientist ever I interviewed him four
years ago and he was one of my first
interviews and he was just he was just
so kind and generous and so it was great
to have him back I had more time to
prepare at the end of the interview
you'll hear the story but I had like 20
minutes to get ready for his interview
based on some timing of things and so
anyway I had much more time this time so
his new book is called to infinity and
beyond we talked a ton about the moon we
talked about the big bang and we talked
about uh asteroids global warming you
know we we hit on a ton of different
things and and extraterrestrials of
course uh unidentified flying objects
UFOs I like call I just can't get down
with the uaps it was so fun so I'm going
to stop talking I'm going to let you
listen to the interview it's a nice good
long one informative as well as funny so
enjoy all great athletes have one thing
in common they take care of their bodies
it's something that we do from a young
age whether we work out the food that we
eat how we prepare our mind this is all
part of becoming a great athlete and one
thing that I do every single morning is
I drink ag1 I do it before I have coffee
I do it before I eat any food I really
feel like for me it's helped my gut
health it's made my stomach just feel
like less bloated and more calm
throughout the day it handles all foods
so much better
I'm putting like 75 high quality
ingredients into my body first thing in
the day which makes a huge difference
even if I'm traveling I use the travel
packs I was in Europe for six weeks
every single day I put ag1 into my body
so if a comprehensive solution is what
you need from your supplement routine
then ag1 is giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com
pretty intense check it out very good
how are you yeah excellent thank you
universe is good I'm good you know it's
Earth that's messed
up fact isn't it is it Earth that's
messed up or is it human beings and that
is also a question too what is a human
being I was looking up something about
that and I was like looking up just like
all kinds of different things there's so
many directions I could go with you and
it's like I feel like I have to like
narrow it down a little bit um or a lot
of bit that I came across was sort of
like ution of humans and then in this
video I was watching it it was just
saying that the that humans there's no
clear definition of
humans yeah well we you know it's what
would be funny is to get an alien to
come onto Earth and then see if they see
any difference between us and anybody
else and any other species because we
like to distinguish ourselves from other
life forms on Earth it's good for our
ego it's quite a Pastime actually
especially when we say how smart we are
compared with other animals and then you
ask well who said we're smart we did we
said we're smart so we we are the
Arbiters of who's smart and we put
ourselves at the top of the list this is
such a human thing to do uh in the
service of our own ego one of the
reasons why a cosmic perspective and
just thinking about and studying the
universe at all has a way of hum ing the
human ego taking you out of the center
of all conversation out of the center of
motion time
space and you end up
resetting your priorities in life when
you achieve that so I think we
can that might have been more a
philosophical question you know what
what is it what is a human maybe they
they decided they couldn't precisely
Define it is there anything that humans
do that no other animal can do other
animals communicate some animals fly we
can't we have to build machines to help
us fly you know so what distinguishes US
other than our
DNA say and we can in in breed with each
other but not with any other animals you
know tigers and lions can have babies
did you know that the liger the liger
yeah my favorite animal you know we know
what humans are as distinct from if you
lined up all the animals sure we would
be able to ID the humans but if you want
to say what makes us human I think
that's a harder question I think about
even like hot and cold at what point is
it hot and at what point is it cold and
it's essentially like a loop or a
Continuum like where did we become human
yeah so that's deep so with hot and cold
I try to you know this is a lost cause
when I attempt this but when I remember
and the situation is right if someone
goes outside and says it's cold
outside I tell them no you should say I
feel cold outside yeah you can't make
some absolute measure of all of of
nature just be your perception of nature
is not the absolute measure of nature so
there's an experiment I did this as a
kid okay you take you get a you get a a
a bowl of like room temperature water
just room temperature and you put it
there between us right now you have your
hand in a bucket of ice and my hand is
in a bucket of very warm water not
enough to harm me and we do that and for
like 30 seconds then we each remove our
hands and put it in the same the same
bowl of water and I whose hand was in
the hot water will say it's cold and you
with your hand in the cold water will
say it's warm and we're touching the
same thing right so this is why not to
get all all deep on you but this is why
we invented science so that we can
bypass the human sensory system of
trying to understand what the world is
and how and why it works because we are
so susceptible to did did you have your
coffee this morning did you what's your
mood are are are you alert were you
wearing your glasses when you should
have been and here we are declaring what
is or is not true in the world when it's
filtering through our highly flawed
senses so when science came on we can
replace our sense of sight and hearing
and sound and touch we can do all of
that we can see things your eyes can't
see we you know the Dead Sea in the
Middle East yeah what you know they call
it dead because there there no fishes in
it but under a microscope there's
microbes doing the backstroke okay they
just didn't have a microscope but they
presumed that their senses was the
ultimate measure of all there is and
when you couldn't see microbes and you
got sick oh my gosh well you did
something bad the day before okay you're
being punished by God or whoever is the
the deity and power and if you had no
idea that you caught a germ from
somebody else because the germ is
smaller than your field of view that
than your capacity to resolve you invent
all kinds of explanations for the world
so where would we be without science I
don't know well then that leads me to
another sort of
big possibly philosophical question
which is because what science is trying
to do is bring things to an objective
truth so what is that oh
so okay so uh objective truth is a very
a definable thing okay that's very
different from absolute truth science
doesn't find absolute we don't know what
the an absolute truth is there could be
a deeper understanding that would come
later that refine whatever was our
understanding before but when I when I
say I've said this before the shorthand
version is the good thing about science
is that it's true whether or not you
believe in it okay now that's that's the
that's the bumper sticker version the
more fleshed out version is if I perform
an experiment and I get a result
especially if the result is unexpected
or
extraordinary what the Press does is
they run to it and say oh new truth oh
everyone will have to go back to the
draw it's like chill just chill okay uh
we need to verify this and do this a
hundred times again especially if it's
an extraordinary claim so get somebody
else get your friend to test it oh wait
a minute they're your friend okay get
someone who's a competitor to test it
all right get someone who tests it in
with a different wall current maybe
there's something in the 120 volt get a
240 volt experiment on it try under at
night and day when you do this if all of
those experiments even from your
competitors show up about approximately
the same result you're on to
something and you have a new objective
truth and what makes it objective is
that other people can verify it who live
outside of your sensory system and even
outside of your
apparatus so yeah E equals MC squ that's
you know we're done there all right
don't come to me say I think E equals MC
cubed that's not how it works you you
don't have that option to declare your
own truth about objectively established
uh
experimental um results in nature did
you know that when we we my particle
physics Brethren uh discovered the
famous higs ban okay but I have a higs
ban joke you want I love it
my kind of
joke yeah I don't know if you knew but
the higs Bon is a particle that was
recently discovered which was
hypothesized to and indeed does Grant
Mass to other particles so that's a
badass if you had to be a particle that
that you know that's the you sitting
there in your chair puffer of particles
oh I love that beautiful Puppeteer
that's it you've got the strings the
mass strings of all the part okay not
strength Theory though let's not confus
that's another thing thank you so the
the higs bosan joke which is traceable
to a guy who's got a Twitter handle ex
handle um science comedian Brian mow is
his name he invented this joke okay not
many jokes do you know the originator
you have all the best funny science
people you are you are basically a
comedian no no the universe is hilarious
and I'm just revealing that to whoever
will like so here it goes you ready higs
boan walks into a
church and the priest says sorry we
don't allow higs bans in church he says
but without me you can't have
mass it's good but it's it's stupid
right okay I like it the point of why
I'm saying that is the huge particle
accelerator the largest in the world by
the way we would have had the largest in
the world um the super conducting super
collider which was fun funded in the
1980s and it got its budget cancelled
right at the beginning of the 1990s this
was going to be built in Texas in fact
they even dug the hole it that would
have been six times more powerful than
the one they ultimately built in
Switzerland so we would have discovered
the higs B on long before the Europeans
would but we zeroed the budget and you
could look up oh there was cost overruns
they'll give no Park the curtains you
know oh what happened at the end of the
80s early 90s H oh I know peace broke
out in Europe and when there's peace do
you need physicists anymore all right
this is no one is gonna tell you I'm
telling you that okay I'm no other
particle accelerator got its budget cut
for the entire 20th previously in the
20th century they all got built but we
we the physicist split the atom okay and
made that created the the the the the
geopolitical military climate of the
20th century how much how many
physicists do you have in The Silo not
just how many bombs because a physicist
is the master of matter motion and
energy what is war if not I have energy
over here and I want to put it over
there think about that that's all that
war is I if I have a bullet and I a I
have a gunpowder or whatever is
propelling I pull the trigger I had
energy over here and now I put it over
there that's way back to catapults I
have this energy over here and I want to
put it over there so the physicist has
always been in the center of all this is
these are all off-ramps to a different
point I'm trying to make when the
particle accelerator in
Switzerland discovered the higs
Bon wait can that be verified by any
anybody nobody else has this particle
accelerator so so how do you how do you
square that one result with what I just
told you whereas if you have a result we
got to verify it okay so here's what
they did they created two beams and two
groups of
scientists that
independently studied those
Beams I don't even think they were I'd
have to double check I don't think they
were allowed to even have lunch together
to comment on what they were two
isolated groups of scientists on a split
beam doing it doing the experiment and
then when the when they got the results
they compared them they were
statistically similar and they say yep
we've got a result here so even in the
singular accelerator in the world they
got an independent um measurement from
an independent team
maybe there was a disgruntled graduate
student that put a that put a you know
faked the signal just to mess with
everybody this is a way to mitigate
against that so we take this very
seriously and that's
why when someone rolls aliens in front
of the Mexican Congress okay we all saw
like they turned it into a cake in one
of the memes I saw that that was
hilarious I want a piece of that cake it
did have a kind of a cakey texture face
cake I I saw that so if you bring forth
is like wow aliens this is amazing I'm
thinking to myself let's have others
verify this or falsify okay maybe it's a
hoax or maybe it's real we don't know
when only one person presents it you
just don't know right here's something I
found out have you ever seen mummified
remains or or or fossils um realize
there is no bone here in your nose it's
this hole that goes into your cranium
and so you nose is one of the first
things to decompose right this is just
cartilage right that alien had a nose
that 2,000 year old alien had a little
pointy nose sticking out I said okay
maybe it was fake maybe he got like a
nose job and there nose job they put a
bone in it in there something exactly
you
know um there's no more challenged
findings and Industry than the
scientific Community I mean you know
forget Hollywood and you know getting
you know turned down for roles like
scientists get turned down for so much I
mean you're everything that you guys
find goes through such a rigorous
analyzation by all your fellow
scientists to try and challenge it right
yeah I I I what you just said there is
so under
recognized and
unappreciated by the public when
we uh observe with the telescopes like
the James webspace telescope there's a
telescope allocation committee and you
apply to this committee and generally we
talk about the over subscription rate it
could be 2 to one 4 to One 7 to one 10
to one so somebody this is the peer
review even of your proposal I have a
really cool idea I'm just not convincing
anybody of it all right so does does
that we we miss science well in every
large telescope the director has what's
called director's discretionary time
which which which bypasses the telescope
allocation committee and so the director
can say this is really high risk and no
one thinks it'll work but I think we
should give it a shot right and allocate
that time so we have these things built
into our system we we've been doing this
for centuries and I we're pretty good at
it fact we are better at discovering
objective truths in this world than I
think any other
other
profession that humans have ever
conceived because that's what we do
that's all we do that's why we do
it so you guys have to have your egos in
check every day yes oh oh and another
thing there people who say oh uh I I
have this result someone will publish I
have this result but the establishment
doesn't want you to know about it okay
because they're stuck in their own
beliefs really like really have you ever
been to a science conference we are
arguing all the time there is no we're
not all just sitting back patting each
other on the back agreeing to agree oh
no you could not have written that if
you had been to any science conference
at all we uh and by the way the
controversies and and the contested
ideas are on the
frontier yeah and if if you and I are
scientists we we have this Unwritten PCT
before we even have a conversation and
that ped
is either I'm right and you're wrong
either you're right and I'm wrong or
we're both
wrong we both know this going into the
conversation and you know how the
conversation ends if we don't agree
we'll say okay here's how to solve this
we need this new or extra data let's get
this extra data and that'll help resolve
this bet now let's go have a beer said
no one ever after a political debate no
kidding right right but okay let me let
me let me let me ask like a a roundabout
question of curiosity to the skepticism
that people can have about what's true
and what's
not who funds all of the research and
the labs and the schools and various
different things that are making this
information because if there's anything
that I feel like we've learned over time
time especially recent times is that
money plays a pretty damn big role so
yeah so so very important point so in
scientific professions lately this
wasn't always the case L lately as in
the last 10 or 20 years if you're in a
scientific profession where your results
have Economic
Consequences then you need to disclose
your
funders okay so if you do research that
says this new medicine
is the best one ever and fizer makes the
medicine and fizer funded your research
you got to disclose that okay okay it
doesn't mean that your
research is wrong it's transparency what
it means is you if you're a reader of
This research you want to be extra
skeptical if especially when they're
getting a result that is in the interest
of the funer so in the Pharmaceuticals
and in medical professions where there's
big money in the results of your
experiment if your experiment is testing
one medicine versus another you've got
to disclose all of that again it doesn't
mean your results are wrong yeah but you
may be more susceptible to bias in your
data Gathering and in your analysis and
I'm G to be more careful and I'm gonna
be extra uh my level of scrutiny will be
higher your research paper perhaps
relative to someone else's that's a
whole category of science that goes on
every day my field first the patient
doesn't die and it hardly ever has any
effect on the world economy so our
disclosures are way less interesting to
you okay okay so I have you know I I
discover a new feature about black holes
yes my my funders are listed is it the
National Science Foundation is it some
grant that I got from some Family
Foundation fine but so so in my field
and other fields in the physical
sciences we just simply less susceptible
to bias in that realm for the who the
funer bias our we we're paid we have um
our two my field principal funding
sources is NASA and the National Science
Foundation what's NASA's role
what what is their job okay so other
than well NASA let's remind ourselves
what the acronym stands for the National
Aeronautics and Space
Administration so NASA you've been in an
airplane lately in the last 10 15 years
you ever seen the wing tips they have
this little bit that flip up at the
edges have you seen that yeah that came
from NASA okay that's the Aeronautics
division of NASA they they realized in
their wind tunnel and simulations of of
of flight that there's turbulence on the
tip of the wing turbulence is never good
if you're trying to fly it it puts it
you know this as a driver okay
aerodynamics are really important yeah
yeah what am I telling you you know
Madam you know okay there's plenty of
people that don't race out there please
okay exactly for everybody else if the
if you have turbulence behind your car
then it puts a it's a partial vacuum
really and it pulls a drag on you and so
it takes more fuel to get through that
so the old wing tip they found that
there's a little bit of turbulence there
and if you flip the wing tip up a bit
that Smooths out that turbulence and you
can save 10 15% efficiency in fuel that
pretty which means planes can go farther
you can carry more payload all of this
so NASA worries about Aeronautics and of
course space Research In Space yeah
they'll put humans in space but when
we're not putting humans in space almost
everything we're doing is telescopes in
space space probes um and other things
but as you may know we're going back to
the moon now the Artemis Mission took
the words out of my mouth I was just
thinking why did we stop going to the
Moon don't get me started you don't uh
I'd like to start you up you you you you
okay okay very I'm very I have you know
super fascinated by the moon let the
record show I have a lot of
question you started this okay now the
second word of the title of your podcast
is intense so let's go there all right
so we were last on the moon 51 years
ago that's half a century we have more
technology in our phone now than they
had to like get it get it right there's
more technology in a in a happy birthday
greeting card that you open up and sings
Happy Birthday to you then went to the
moon okay and we had really good self
service for some reason too which is so
weird
so uh we could have stayed on the oh so
1972 Apollo 17 by the way we had Apollo
18 in the wings ready to fly okay then
we oh wait a minute Russia is not going
to the
Moon oh well I guess we don't need to go
to the Moon then because that's why we
went we tell ourselves oh we're
Americans and we're explorers and it's
in our DNA we were scared witless our
damn egos okay we were scared that the
Godless communist Soviet
Union um would would beat us and we
would be the laughing stock of the world
and and then we wouldn't be able to
attract um other interested countries if
if they have to to choose which
direction to go in the future of their
geopolitics and their economies all
right so even though Russia invented the
rocket equation okay you know what the
rocket equation I'll tell you what it is
tell you ready this is an
aside understand but yes please it it's
worth it okay I promise all right if I
tell you it takes um these numbers I'm
using round numbers just so it's easy to
think about but the actual numbers will
follow the same way that I'm describing
if I want to put one pound of payload
into
orbit and it takes one pound of
fuel to do that that's pretty easy to
understand okay now
watch I now want to put two pounds of
payload into
orbit so how much fuel will that take
two gallons okay you'd say two pounds
however
however okay
um you
need okay you need a pound of fuel to
get each of those pounds into orbit but
then you need
fuel to get the fuel you haven't burned
yet okay so now we add another pound of
fuel to get the other pound of fuel into
orbit that we're going to use to get the
second pound of payload into orbit okay
so now I have now I have and now I have
five pounds of stuff okay two pounds of
payload three pounds of fuel now I want
to add another pound of
payload now I have three pounds of
payload okay and three pounds of of fuel
I got to get all of that up there before
that even starts to
burn so so this runs away this is that's
why the Saturn 5 rocket it was 34
stories tall and Astronaut are up a
little
bitt top of the thing and basically
everything else is fuel they're they're
on a vertical bomb okay that's the
tyranny of the rocket equation okay why
do I begin there because Russians
invented the rock discovered the rocket
equation that was 110 120 years ago
Russians did that Russians had the first
satellite Sputnik Russians had the first
non-human animal like a the dog very sad
because they never planned to bring the
dog back alive there were no heat
shields so everybody's sad about that
but I'm not sad can I tell you can I
tell I'm not sad because that was a
homeless dog in Moscow I'm thinking I'm
thinking you go from homeless to being
the most famous dog in the world after
Lassie I'm going into I'm going into
space okay rather than die Frozen on an
alley in Moscow okay Journey okay so uh
the Russians had the first human in
space yuria Garen the first female in
Space the first black person in space it
was a dark skinned Cuban they had the
first space station they had real space
station they they they did all of this
we're watching them just kick our ass
and then we said we got to do something
so we go to the Moon before they do and
then we say we win how how how how did
we how I mean was it just because we
were just like a little behind on
technology or is it because we hired a
bunch of Russian scientists to help us
do it or
we had German rocket stist who who they
they were the ones who invented the V2
rocket and from the second world war and
no they were not lined up in nerenberg
to be hanged like other Nazis okay we
kept them and a story that can only
happen in America these are former Nazis
building America's
rockets at a location in
Alabama which is like the seat of the
Civil Rights Movement just just this
this jua position it's like throw a
bunch of ingredients in there shake it
up and you got a bomb to take you to
the so and anyhow so we get to the moon
say we win then we find out the Russians
are not going to the moon so we stop to
not go we beat them I I don't know or
they realized it was no longer strategic
scientifically I I can't get inside
their heads but once we confirmed they
were not going we stopped and we
orphaned and mothballed Apollo 18 so we
could have stayed on the moon but
science and research was not the goal
stayed meaning go back keep going back
we could have stayed in 1972 but we
didn't it just kept going Apollo 18 19
20 21 but we didn't we didn't do you
know how many scientists went to the
moon out of all those Apollo missions I
don't know one one know which Mission it
was the last
mission the last mission so it was not
really about science even though science
piggybacked the whole operation so let's
just get real about this all right so uh
do we go back in 1980 no 1990 no 2000 no
2010 no wait a minute China China wants
to go to the into space they launched
their first tyena they build a a space
station they go they that landing on the
moon that with with robots they want to
put people on the moon then we say hey
why don't we go back to the moov so so
here we are being reactive to the forces
to the geopolitical forces rather than
proactive and that saddens me a little
because that's you can sort of lead the
world that way if you're sort of bullied
or threatened or scared into jumping
ahead but I as a scientist I would have
rather have known that our curiosity was
there all along so we're going back to
China is going back to the moon and so
are we there it is I just wonder like
what's the Cascade effect of beating
them because it just can't be just ego
right like it's it we're not necessarily
trying to recruit more people to come
live in the United States probably like
what is the reason why this is so
important I I guess it's to me it feels
like feels like look we need to be we
need to get there because we're like
defending the moon essentially but what
are they defending what is on the dark
side secret mineral deposits um
moon right it's the it's the new High
Ground maybe that's how you should think
about it yeah what does that mean what
do you mean by that well
militaristically you have high
ground uh you're harder to challenge
you're no so what happens if China lands
on the moon and puts up a Chinese flag
you know we'll lose our okay over
that the flag won't matter well but
they're they're waiting for us like you
know ships arriving to obey and
everybody waiting to take them down like
yeah it's it's it's it would be symbolic
of a of an American failure to maintain
presence on the moon and so yeah I think
ego we started this conversation about
ego right the human ego it's not only
our species but there's a nationalistic
ego as well of
course and it can get ugly all right
when India landed on the moon South Pole
they were the first country to do that
the fourth country to land on the moon
at all say to land Softly on the moon
you know they have tensions between
India and Pakistan right India is mostly
Hindu one out of six of them is Muslim
uh Pakistan is mostly Muslim and they've
had tensions like you know ever since
1947 or whenever the split occurred when
Gandhi was running around by the way the
the Indian Rover that land on the South
Pole on its treads is an imprint of the
Indian flag so as it rolls around the
the the dust tread is a flag design yes
so it'll leave an imprint of the flag as
it goes around so that's called that's a
that's that's the moon's version of
marking your territory you
know no that's the Rover's version of
peeing on the tree at wherever it went
right exactly exactly that's called yeah
that's lifting a leg on the moon yeah
yeah so so I saw this meme that said
because of course uh Pakistan has a a a
crescent moon and a star which is very a
sacred symbol of Islam SYM symbolizing
many things but especially the beginning
of Ramadan um and that star typically is
Venus if it's in the sky but the real
measure is that crescent moon but anyway
that's on the flag okay so I saw this
Meme and I said damn I thought only
Americans were this
obnoxious this was my first thought it
meme said uh in Pakistan they have the
moon on their flag but in India we have
our flag on the moon cute C I mean ego
for sure but there's got to be money
involved I'm skeptical for sure but like
let's just talk about like the the
science of the
Moon and how we got it and what its role
is because it's like a really
critical element to our planet for the
tilt of the Earth for for the tides for
the seasons it's also oddly large
compared to the earth when you're
looking at the rest of the planets is
this correct everything you said is
about 90% correct so you are you are
right that makes me feel like I got like
an A A not A+ just clean a a straight A
okay uh the Moon is oddly large compared
with the moons of other planets and the
size of the their host planet right so
just so you know Jupiter has this famous
red spot which is a weather system been
raging for several hundred years at
least and the Earth relative to Jupiter
would easily fit inside of Jupiter's red
spot yeah okay yet our
moon is if it were around Jupiter be
like Jupiter's second biggest moon okay
so ganam is I think a little bigger than
our moon just a little so we have our
moon is badass there's no two ways about
so that's unusual about it the moon does
stabilize the tilt of our
AIS without the moon the tilt of our
axis would vary by much more which would
make ferocious fluctuations in the
seasons which is which you hinted at in
your comment called living in the
midwest there you
go was it 115 out there you're in
Arizona now yeah Arizon but I grew up in
Chicago area and there's ferocious
changes of
seasons and
so uh so we like the moon you know we
you know there's an old saying in the
space Community if God wanted us to have
a space program he would have given us a
moon well there is a moon
okay it was an interesting backd door
way to say yeah of course we have a
space program because we have a place we
want to go with it all right so um so
now is what is the value of it well
there's the value of the technology that
got you there there's always spin-offs
and patents sure of course yeah I mean
race cars make road cars better by
adding paddle shifting and being able to
change the shocks inside the car and I
do it all the time so yes yes I get it
totally and by the way Danica I had not
appreciated how much uh NASCAR
especially but all of car racing uh the
Innovations in in car racing would
trickle down to just me driving down the
street pulling up at the stop sign
you're welcome for the rough
ride it's called rigid the rig rigid
suspension but it handles really
well oh by the way I I'm about to post
this a slight aside uh I I don't mean to
brag but uh some years ago I was invited
to write a piece for Car and Driver
magazine for their annual speed issue
and so I wrote a piece and I said no
it's not about speed you say it's about
I feel the need for no it's not speed
okay it's acceleration that you're
actually
after and that's what you feel that's
what you you're go right now we're on
Earth Earth is going 18 miles per second
around the Sun yeah okay when you're in
an airplane at 31,000 feet you're going
500 mil mil an hour yeah terminal veloc
really what you're after in Top Gun
which I feel the need for speed when
they talk about their flight they're
talking about the barrel rolls and all
of the things that the plane is doing
when it's changing its speed or when
it's changing its direction both of
those are accelerations and so that and
you want rigid suspension so you could
feel the road yeah that's what you you
want to feel the road and that's you're
you're having these micro acceler ation
in your body yeah so I'm just putting it
out there so so I just narrated a video
essay of that I'm gonna post it to oh
that's great what what a timely thing
that you've just done and I think I
called it um uh no is it it's not it's
not as catchy as I feel the need for
speed it it I have to NE necessitate the
need to accelerate this there's some
lame there's plenty of time to rename it
I feel the need for speed but anyhow yes
that so that the uh the the
spin-off Technologies uh oh my gosh I
mean you pulled up your smartphone which
by the way communicates via cell phone
towers to GPS satellites this is space
technology all right so so you it's hard
to predict in what ways it will uh
improve our lives change our lives uh
push civilization forward however the
word forward is defined there of course
but um when you have the new High Ground
not only uh physically but also
scientifically and geopolitically
there's no telling who's going to be in
charge of the world in the future so I
think our
geopolitics sort of dictates that we try
to keep up with the Chinese just the way
we kept up with the Soviets why are we
always at War I mean you talked about
war at the very beginning and I wonder
if there's sort of like like an ability
to draw draw some similarities between
it because so I wrote a whole book on
this I wrote a whole book on this called
accessory to war the unspoken alliance
between astrophysics and the military
and because we go way back you don't you
didn't know where you were on Earth
unless you can
triangulate off of stars with a seant or
an astrol and so that all the big um SE
fairing Powers had astronomers like
right next to them helping them figure
out where they are on earth so they can
return if you're if you're the Conqueror
you want to be able to return and keep
conquering or you w to know your way
back so all of this all the seafaring
era of this world where wars were fought
as Naval battles primarily uh they all
needed astronomers to figure that out um
we didn't build the weapons but we
enabled the weapons to hit their target
okay so uh so there's that so now here's
what I'm going to tell you now on Earth
you can draw lines and I can say don't
cross that line well why can't I oh well
because you worship a different God than
I do you sleep with a different people
than I do your skin color reflects light
differently than mine well I have access
to resources and you don't and I will
kill you if you want access to the same
resources this is the kind of stuff that
humans use to wage organ Gan war against
each other okay can you draw lines in
space
no how do you
know so AR Line's always changing we're
hurling through space at what speed 18
miles per second around the Sun so
Arthur C Clark noted and that's flying
through space Oh yeah yeah so and all
right so I can finish that out the the
Sun and all its attendant planets and
comets and asteroid
the entire system is orbiting the center
of the Galaxy at
about 20 miles per second so way faster
than Earth orbiting the Sun so here's
what's cool about that the whole system
is also moving so we think we're in this
closed orbit around the Sun but we're in
fact in a
helix spiraling through space as the
entire system moves around the center of
the Galaxy where there's a super massive
black hole so yeah you want speed I got
speed that's not so that's not really
what you're after I want acceleration
thank
you fast study right there you got it
so um so my sense of this is maybe
because you can't draw lines in
space and because if you hoisted a flag
There's No Air for it to
furl a flag would just hang
limp maybe space is not a place for
countries maybe space is a place to
collaborate coordinate
participate on asteroids there's an
unlimited amount depend choose your
asteroid there's an unlimited resources
I just learned that that if you want a
mine for any kind of element that you
want
go to an asteroid correct even the
rarest most precious elements on Earth
there are asteroids with more platinum
on them in them than all the Platinum
that has ever been mined on Earth there
you go yeah yeah I'm sure so um so
there's that there's unlimited energy
247 drawn from the Sun you you can lassu
a comet and you'd have unlimited fresh
water and there billions of comets
so it may be that in the future the
solar system becomes our
backyard then maybe an entire category
of organized Warfare goes away overnight
and that's the war fought over access to
limited resources resources exactly
because they'll be unlimited there's no
reason to fight anymore correct and you
might be angry that someone is charging
too high a price
or
yeah go another asteroid is out there
correct exactly right what about when
you were mentioning the moon and the I I
giving that giving us sort of a glimpse
as to the size of the Moon and Earth
compared to the moons on Jupiter let's
say and gravity at work is like the
larger the mass the more gravity so how
is it that we're not pulling the moon
into us and colliding essentially
because of the Mass difference like
you'd think that that would attract it
right or swallow it up what like how
does that work so Danica I love the way
your brain is wired for thought and for
inquiry so so here we go I'm gonna give
you an answer you is more than you
bargain for but you are so deserving of
this answer are you ready yeah Isaac
Newton no he wasn't hitting the head
with an apple but he did wonder why does
an apple fall straight to Earth yet the
moon does
not how is it that the moon could be
part of the Earth Moon system orbit the
Earth but how come it doesn't just fall
to Earth's surface that's the question
you're asking that's the question he
asked yeah sitting under an apple tree
and if you didn't waste your life racing
cars you could have been the next
Newton
we do have to laugh a little there I'm
not very good at math but I am quite
good at asking questions okay so of
course you didn't waste your life we
wouldn't be having this conversation if
you didn't do all you did in life true
so um so all I'm I'm just telling you
you ask the same questions of nature all
right whether or not you knew it
so he thought to himself all right let
me go to a Mountaintop and and set up a
cannon
and let's shoot out a a cannon a
cannonball and you shoot it out and it
it comes to the bottom of the mountain
it falls okay so the whole time even
though it has sideways motion The
Cannonball is falling it eventually hits
the ground okay clearly all right what
happens if
you if you if you if the Cannonball
comes out at a higher speed further it
will land farther away for hits the
Earth agreed yep of course okay let's
keep doing this let's make it come out
even
faster even
faster and watch what's happening The
Cannonball is now going so far from the
cannon it is sort of following the
curvature of the
earth before it hits it's got to curve
and then hit hit the
Earth okay and then he said wait a
minute is there a speed where when I
launch the launch when I um uh uh shoot
out the cannon
ball where it'll continue to
fall but wait a minute Earth is
completely turned away from it and it if
now you duck otherwise it'll hit you in
the back of the head and then the
Cannonball would just continue
oh my gosh in that he drew this diagram
in his most fam one of his most famous
books okay a Newton system of the world
he drew this diagram and that was the
first description of an
orbit an
orbit there is a speed with which you go
down range so
far that when you're falling towards
Earth the very Cur curvature of Earth's
surface fell away from you by that same
amount so you fall shot almost like it
kind of slingshots it around no well
well it's it's a stable thing so you
fell a foot towards Earth Earth curved
the foot away from you yeah yeah yeah
yeah between ah got it got it got it
okay so so you are actually falling
towards
Earth the Moon is Falling Towards Earth
Earth it's just going sideways fast
enough so that it's
always it's never catching up with
Earth's curved surface and it completes
the orbit that's why to maintain an
orbit you don't need Rockets things in
orbit they're stable just orbiting one
of the most stable things you can do
Earth around the Sun the moon around
Earth our that's this is why when you
see a rocket launch we say it's going to
launch into space What is the the first
thing you see the rocket do Regal launch
pad they
curve they curve okay they don't just go
straight up they don't go up very high
before they start going down range half
the fuel that they burn is to give it
sufficient speed give it this new magic
Newtonian speed so that it is going down
rain so fast that as it falls towards
Earth Earth curves away from it at
exactly the same rate and there's one
speed at a given height that does that
and that's called that's the orbital
speed so if the space station it's about
five miles per
second
sideways but that's also what let me
keep going here all right um you know
the
billionaire Bezos Branson boys Rocket
Race okay musk so uh unlike Elon
who puts people into orbit Bezos and
Branson don't they just launch you up
and then they sort of drop you and
you're in free fall for a short period
of time before you reencounter the
atmosphere why are they doing that while
you're in free fall you're
weightless right okay if I put you in an
elevator in a tall building cut the cut
the cable while you're falling you're
weightless if I put you on a scale yep
and it registers your current weight and
then I want a free fall forever I want a
freef fall that's it I want so watch
watch so I cut the cable the elevator
Falls to Earth the scale Falls to Earth
and you fall to Earth and if you are
holding uh like
a a a pen or pencil in front of you
after you cut the cable if you let
go the elevator the scale you and the
pencil are falling to Earth at exactly
the same rate and the pencil will float
in front of you oh I can say is when I
went skydiving I did a Bear Grills
running wild show and at the end we had
to skydive to our location and I
described it like I was like standing on
air once you fell you don't feel like
you're falling anymore you just kind of
feel like you're standing on air well so
the the how does it all fall at the same
rate though the most magic time of that
fall would be until you have reached
what they say terminal velocity yes you
surely hit terminal velocity which I
think depending your density are you
dense or you I'm definitely I mean
definitely uh ask questions uh it's uh
interal velocity for a human body
somewhere between 100 and 200 miles an
hour depending how Flappy your clothes
are and whether you wear these drag wing
tips exactly depending on what other
stuff is there to resist the air um so
all I'm saying is when you're in free
fall you are
weightless
so when you're in orbit you are freely
Falling Towards
Earth you just happen to be going
sideways so fast you never catch up with
Earth but you are Free Falling Towards
Earth and that is why astronauts in
orbit are weightless it's not because
they're just in space there's nothing
inherently weightless about being in
space no no you are weightless in a
falling elevator the Bezos Branson
Taurus are weightless until they
reencounter the atmosphere anybody in an
orbiting spacecraft is weightless it's
Falling Towards Earth but you're going
fast enough that you don't get there
correct because Earth is round and it
curves away from you it's
round sorry I I I didn't want to be that
person to break the news to you yeah
there's a lot lot lot of funny memes I
think my favorite one was when you said
that when there was the shadow of Earth
on something and it was just a
flatline
when I saw you do your your talk back in
the day it was like what I said was
conversations with a astrophysicist or
something so there's a full moon and
there's a shadow there's just a thin
horizontal Shadow across the full moon I
said a lunar eclipse flat earthers have
never seen yeah be Earth
Shadow yeah on that just as a curiosity
I would say cuz I I get into a lot of
interesting spaces and your science and
so I don't think this is totally out of
bounds for science but I would say
because there's plenty of people that
you know think the Earth is flat or
something's different about it and I'm
like it's not I was like it's far more
likely that it's holographic in nature
than it and why we can't maybe explain
everything than it is that
it's flat we're gonna we're pro have you
ever entertained that idea of a
holographic reality well there are a lot
of things we could be and the
holographic universe is a competing idea
right now it's an authenticly advanced
idea by an authentic physicist
to consider the possibility that none of
this is real in any physical sense right
that it's just information sort of
manifested in this sort of holographic
grid and that's a hard pill to swallow I
think but it's intrig and it may lead to
other sort of physical insights in into
the universe about whether Earth is flat
and we have people running around saying
it isn't you know there's an old saying
I think it's 85% true that if an
argument lasts more than five minutes
then both sides are wrong
no yeah how long will you argue with
someone who says Earth is
flat right or it's the scientific
Community you're right I'm wrong I'm
right you're wrong or we're both wrong
that's correct that's correct and we
both have to recognize that going into
the conversation so my my favorite
rebuttal to flight earthers are uh have
you ever been on the East Coast on a
Sunday in the winter and watched a
football game on the west
coast okay a football game on a Sunday
in the
winter uh it gets dark in New York at
5:00
the sun is still up in San Francisco or
in Los Angeles that's because Earth is
curved just just start there start there
that's a free experiment that Network
television is bringing to you okay
so yeah and the and the sun we rotate
west to east so the sun sets in the west
and the Sun is still over that Stadium
two and a half thousand argument is that
that the curvature should make certain
things disappear at a certain
distance and yet it seems like that's
not the case that to me is like their
the hang their hat on one yeah yeah I
don't think they did the math on that is
I sure should didn't I can promise you
that like
promise but I watch a YouTube video
about it of course yeah of course let's
close the loop on the moon because I
told you I'm super duper fascinated by
the moon correct something which is why
you got an A instead of an A+ um there
is no Dark Side of the
Moon I'm that's where I was going why
don't we see the other side of it oh
there's a Far Side there's a Far Side of
the Moon that we never see you're
getting me on a technicality I like it
well no it's not it's not all sides of
the Moon get sunlight exactly that's
what you're yeah I I understand okay so
so The Far Side of the Moon when it's
new moon for us it's broad daylight for
them so day on the moon lasts uh
basically a month a day on the moon so
the sun rises and sets um and completes
its day cycle on the moon one about once
a month 29 and a half days to be precise
do we ever see that is it ever does any
part of the planet ever see the other
side okay so now watch so I'm facing
though we are on a podcast Zoom exchange
I'm looking at you and there's a
painting behind you correct M verify
that yes there is there's a very red and
yellow and
brown I love it flash across the back of
me here he goes so I'm facing that
painting right now if we were in the
same room and I went to the other side
of you and you you rotated to still and
I now I'm still facing
you if I'm on the other side of you and
I'm still facing you I'm not facing that
painting I'm facing whatever is behind
me right now yeah I'm it'd be my
direction now okay I had to rotate 180
degrees for that to
happen so I am turning on my
Axis now it turns out this turning has
an exact
match so one day on the moon exactly
matches one orbit of the moon it's
what's called tily
locked and then people say I can't what
what are the odds of that how can that
be what how because the Moon is rotating
at exactly the rate necessary to always
show the same face to us okay it's
called a tidy locked system and the
forces of nature conspire to tidy lock
things in the universe and Earth has
tially locked the Moon the Moon is try
trying to tially lock us the Moon is
slowing down our rotation did anybody
tell you that it is slowing down we
we've had to introduce 20 3 24 leap
seconds since we discovered this effect
back 50 years ago 24 leap seconds to
compensate for the fact that the Moon is
trying to slow us down because one day
when the moon
succeeds it will slow us down so much so
that we will only ever show the same
face to the
Moon then you get a double tital
lock wow and is that plut and its Moon
Karen or it might be Karen depending if
it's Greek or Roman pronunciation the
they are I they're in a double tital
lock and is that inevitable for Earth
yeah it is but it could take longer than
the life of the sun um it's happening
slowly but it's real and Double T so it
means for
earthlings when the moon is up it never
sets and if you can't see the moon it
will never rise like on the moon if if
you're on The Far Side of the Moon you
would not even know an earth existed
until you hiked around to the near Side
of the Moon and then well you can see
the Earth crazy there wouldn't be like a
little bit of a shift though because
even in the atmosphere like we're
looking at the stars the stars have
shifted over time like yes they have
you're looking at the alignment of
things they've they've all shifted just
a little bit based on time passing yeah
so Earth Earth in it Earth wobbles on
its axis right we have a tip and that
wobble wobble shifts the correspondence
of the Stars to the month in the year
that we normally associate them with so
yeah all of that'll shift but when
you're tially locked you're tially
locked and uh so I used to wrestle and
in college and in high school and
college I was Captain and undefeated in
high school but in college it was
different because it got harder yeah it
got harder I I expected that but no I I
be wrestling these like cornfed guys
from the ranch who were probably hauling
Cals you know when they were children ba
and hay yeah so I'm a city kid and I
there was no contest for them but I
still love the sport and I wanted to
invent a new wrestling hold called the
double title HCK my God that is the
coolest nerdiest thing ever so so I
managed I figured one out but I never I
never performed it in competition so it
have to be arms and legs well no so what
would happen is uh I would I would lock
arms with your arms so now we're facing
each other like that but I have to be in
control of your body and I we would spin
while I'm dragging you down to the mat
and so we are turning facing each other
but I take you to the mat yeah I already
have you as long as you stay in front of
me your your shoulder blades go to the
mat and then we it's a take down to a
pin that's gonna happen some I think
that you just you got to get a hold of
Joe Rogan and get him
to he's got a whole a whole exercise
facility behind his uh recording studio
we have to try do it in I'm bigger than
he is so a little awkward to make that
happen but it'd be a good video though
next time you go to Joe's show you
should tell him about the double title
lock and show them how it goes I'm
fascinated by the big bang and what it's
all about and my mind says the Big Bang
how do you know what the big bang is
unless it happens on some other scale on
some fractal scale in some other way or
otherwise this big bang that happened is
just something that was you know 14
billion years ago and we how do we have
any evidence like what what is the big
bang and does it happen on a fractal
level in other ways that we experience
in our reality you want
evidence that's also another question I
had what is evidence okay all right so
if You Came Upon a fireworks display all
right and one of the more pretty ones is
the the one that looks like a
chrysanthemum if you
studied the direction and speed of all
of those bits and pieces of that
explosion okay even if you weren't there
at the beginning of it you can say what
happens if I turn the clock back well I
see which way it's going now let me go
backwards along that
path and I do that for all the bits and
pieces of that firework what I will find
is that all the pieces will rejoin
themselves at some point in the past for
the fireworks of course it's just a
matter of seconds well we we did a
calculation very similar to this for the
entire universe we look at all the
galaxies of the universe and they're
expanding away from one
another and we say well with expanding
away that means they were closer
yesterday and last year and 10 years ago
a million years ago a billion years ago
let's keep turning the clock back and
when you do that the entire universe was
in the same place at the same
time we call that the big
bang no we did not observe it but all
evidence
points to
it and everything you can track
everything to go back on itself because
there's a continuous division happening
not only that creates an expans as if
you go back into the universe is getting
cooler right now if you go back in time
the universe was hotter you can ask the
question what effect does that
temperature have on matter and energy
you can do that in a particle
accelerator get very high energies and
very high temperatures and pressures
when you do that you learn what matter
does then you apply that to the early
Universe yeah and you can predict things
that we currently see in the universe
how much helium is there how much
lithium what the where do you find all
the matter where did it go does it
coales yes it does when does it coales
after the Dark Ages is a period of time
where matter is still
cooling such that it's cool enough to
form basic
coherent solid objects if you're too
warm you're not going to collapse okay
so we have an entire understanding of
the Universe from The Big Bang onward
and it's very works very well with the
data if there's a day where we find
there's some missing bits and
pieces it's not gonna it will not likely
Force us to discard the Big Bang instead
it will say oh the big bang is an
embedded part of a larger truth sure I
it was something Beyond The Big Bang
that correct that's the Multiverse a
looping essentially on something where
the big bang and then it's like entropy
into collapse into whatever and then
could be just could be a small microcosm
of a bigger story that's unfolding but
all the evidence we have for the Big
Bang itself that's not just going to
walk away right it's there and it's
sound so and evid
is how do how would I Define evidence no
one's ever asked me that um evidence
is uh I can't Define it I looked it up
because I was like I was I I was looking
it up for various different things
including like the Congressional hearing
and you know hearing things and I've
heard you say many times like where's
the evidence of
extraterrestrials tell what is not
evidence putting your hand on a Bible
and swearing you're going to tell the
truth that's not EV that's not
scientific if evid I I don't you you
could believe you're telling the truth
even if you're not but testimony is part
of evidence that's in the definition
testimony yeah testimony in legal sense
I need a witness says the lawyer and
said a scientist never ever okay so uh
generally evidence is something tangible
that doesn't flow through the senses of
the human your human brain sensory
system so an artifact if you're abducted
by aliens you know steal an ashtray off
the shelf and bring it to the lab then
it could be an item of alien
manufacturer we would know immediately
like instantly but we're all made of
everything's made of the same stuff
that's true but if it's some so maybe
not ashray would not be a good example
some bit of Technology that's on on
board but aren't we bring that one of
the things they did say was that there
is I mean and it's been totally a rumor
forever that reverse engineering C
crashed I call them UFOs it just feels
better it's like calling it's like
living in Chicago and calling the SE the
Sears Tower the Willis Tower I'm not
doing it um so but that's been a that's
been a a a rumor forever that that yeah
and the rumor is they they have it in a
lab somewhere and they're not letting
anyone else see it and that's not how
science works if you have an
alien I don't care how interesting the
alien is but if it's in a lock box
somewhere and no one can see it but you
and your chosen friends and it's not
made available to others other
scientists specifically to investigate
it then the alien in your closet is no
different from having no alien at all to
the rest of us it that distinction is
not is not even made what if we end up
re learning um that they have had this
stuff all along fine but I'm just saying
I would like evidence of that yeah and
evidence of it would be oh my gosh you
did well here folks okay it would just
be odd that all the alien evidence only
came to American Military authorities
right it's a big world at any given
moment there's a million people
Airborne yeah with a window and they
have smartphones so they could take
pictures of motherships if we're getting
visited alien invasions
so on the ground I live an epicenter
here in Phoenix yes you
do why does Area 51 I I drove by Area 51
a couple weeks ago on my way to Burning
Man and it was like there all there is
is an Area 51 Superstore which is fun
but I got a couple T-shirts um what what
I mean it's a humongous space Area
51 what the hell is going on like why is
it off why is it off limits for people
like why well of course of course the
government will do top secret things if
if it's in the interest of National
Security the real question is how secret
would it manage to keep it right it
seems to me if we're stockpiling aliens
at Area 51 the janitor would sneak a
photo of it post it lose his job the
next day but be the most famous richest
janitor there ever was like the dog like
the like the like the like the the one
that got to go to space like
have your moment have your moment that
would be it Leica Leica is the dog yeah
so I I'm not saying we haven't been
visited I'm saying what has been put
forth as evidence would not convince a
skeptical scientist yeah we are we are
more skeptical about less stuff than
alien visitation so don't take it
personally have you ever had anything
happen have you ever had like a mystical
weird extraterrestrial unexplainable
experience that
I've been looking up since I was nine so
when you do that that early you learn
things you learn meteorology you learn
um about climate clouds
lightning um moons Venus in the sky so
you learn a lot from early on but here's
how I will answer your question in my
life I've seen maybe a dozen or 15
things that if I did not not have the
high level of understanding of what can
happen in our atmosphere that I
did I would have easily reported them as
UFOs so no I've never seen anything I
could not explain I know most people
would not otherwise be able to explain
sure sure sure amount of wanting it to
be true that plays a role too of course
well that's that's the that's the bias
effect of course so the other day like
this was a few weeks ago I was in my
backyard and there was I never even told
anyone cuz it wasn't that big of I
didn't know what to make of it but it
was a little flash of light that came
like at me and then went down and it was
probably about 20 feet away and it was
it was a bright light that made like a
like it came at me and dropped down and
disappeared like what could explain that
was it was it 20 feet away yeah why you
go pick it up go go to where it was
that's a good question there's a fence
I'd have to like go in listen if you if
it's alien stuff climb the fence I don't
care that there's a fence okay you're
tougher than
that I can C oh there's a fence I can't
get over the fence okay true but what
could explain something like that like a
a large light flash in the air I I don't
know uh people now have drones that have
lights on them and if they're facing you
it can be bright and drones can change
their position rapidly vertically up and
down the trees it was probably only like
10t speed up yeah so um drones you ever
seen someone manipulate drones they're
quite Nimble in this regard my first
guess is it might have been a drone my
last guess is that it's aliens from
another planet who are spying on you in
your
backyard either way they're curious
about me ah but next time be curious
about it scale that fence find out where
it dropped to grab it and then call me
back
you're the first person I'm
calling I can tell you this when the
aliens come and they say take me to your
leader I ain't taking him to the
president I'm
sorry not doing that okay I'm gonna call
over some of my friends and we're gonna
have a beer with the alien all right
what if they have alien beer would you
take their alien beer totally I would
totally try it yes that's that's part of
the the the Deep cultural binding forces
that go on when you in a new culture you
try their food right and that's a vote
of V bonding it's a bonding vote yeah
bonding and respect okay back to the
back to the universe uh recently they
said the universe is about twice as old
as supposedly we thought it was a
clickbait headline that someone reported
but no one else verifies it and so it
just became clickbait yeah huh so
there's nothing to that yeah they're
assuming that the speed of light was
different in the early universe than
today and if it were then we'd be Mis
assessing the age of the universe but uh
no there's no one agreed with that
result so but it it was out there long
enough to get clickbait and have
everybody wondering about it so yeah how
important do you think it is for us to
get off planet and then How likely do
you think it will
be like off I like being a multiplet
species but for a different reason than
others have stated Carl Sean said we
should be and stepen Hawking we should
be a multiplan species in case something
bad happens here then at least some
record of our species survives and I'm
thinking well what bad are you what are
you thinking about what oh an asteroid a
killer
asteroid oh so what you're saying is we
should terraform Mars ship a billion
people there in case an asteroid comes
and takes out all human beings on Earth
really it seems to me if you have the
Geo engineering necessary to terraform
Earth the terraform to turn Mars into
Earth then and the space program to ship
a billion people you could probably
deflect the asteroid that's all I'm
saying is that too much to ask that is a
question I have how that would how could
that happen it it doesn't take much
I in your book and you deflect it if you
deflected 1 cimeter per second that's a
small deflection but if you get it early
enough that one s me just keeps
accumulating okay and eventually it
would miss Earth entirely either coming
by ahead of it or if you slow it down it
would come in behind it so so I want to
be on multiplet just because it would be
fun not because I'm prepared to accept
that half my fellow members of my
species are going to die because they
because they bet on the wrong planet no
that's not where I'm going with that fun
so you'd go to Mars then oh yeah give me
a good streaming account because it
takes a few months to get there yeah
right well you got to go in for the long
sleep right isn't that my favorite movie
is Interstellar so you go in for the
long sleep when they go in the little
tube and they kind of put them out and I
think they sleep for you know months and
months I think the long sleep is
overrated you want to be awake I think
it's overrated because your body still
has to stay alive yeah so you'll have a
metabolism it's just a little bit
slower so and they don't want to use up
the ship's resources but these are huge
ships with like seemingly unlimited
energy
so just leave me awake keep me awake I
wanna I want to see the universe as we
travel through it what about the idea of
inner earth and like going into the
Earth to protect yourself if something
were to happen is there any like is that
even feasible yes so that's probably the
safest place to be in an asteroid strike
but for you but if it renders other life
extinct that you depend on as food
sources you'll go extinct eventually
anyway it just delays the
inevitable so you might as well go stand
under where the asteroid's gonna
hit first time I went bunge jumping in
New Zealand listen to you but I think
they invented bungee jumping in New
Zealand they did and I went to literally
the original bungee jump in the whole
world and it was weird because I saw it
the day before and I was like I'm scared
of heights I also told you story about
skydiving I just like to make sure that
I can do it if I need to and then the
next day I'm doing a wine tasting next
to it and the girl that was doing it
said oh yeah I uh that's the original
bungee jump I worked there do you want
to go and for some reason I brought I
was wearing a dress and I brought a
t-shirt and shorts and I was like yes
yes I want to go and I had 20 minutes to
wrap my head around it and I went over
there and anyway I step up to the end of
the plank and it's like one of the have
you ever bunge jumped nope nope they're
like toes to the line and then you get
to the line they're like no no toes to
the edge and you have to hop CU you're
bound you have to hop your toes up to
the line before
you oh right right because you you dive
off yeah it holds you by your ankles
that's right so it's one thing like if
someone pushes you because you just
happens but when you actually have to
use your own muscle and will and mind to
jump your body off you're like oh no I'm
GNA actually like purposely do this it's
a whole different thing but I went on
two this is why I'm telling the story
because I was like if I wait till 3 I
might not go and I just peacefully swand
do my way down because I thought if I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go peacefully oh okay
so the asteroid you just stand under it
yeah yeah okay that's interesting State
of Mind like if these are my last
moments on
Earth let let it be a 10.0 on the dive
scale
exactly from all judges observing go out
in
style now in the vend
diagram of people who are afraid of
heights people who bungee jump and
people who race
cars you are surely the only person in
the intersection of those three
circles just I'm telling you I don't
think of myself as Brave okay uhuh well
yeah I'm staying in the plane I'm stay
I'm not no no to many other ways to die
in this world like not on purpose I
don't want to I don't want to Aid in a
bet my own yeah I try I really don't
like doing things where I think I could
die which is why like I have a tether or
a parachute or wheels or walls you know
these seem like a they seem like an
extra layer of protection speaking of
protection um I just want to touch on
I'm curious about global warming
because it's such a topic where you know
there's I I I get confused and I was
looking at some like old records of up
to a million years old of the
temperature changes and it comes and
goes all the time yes it does and we're
totally on an upswing we're like at
quite at the top not as far as but the
difference is we're causing it that's
the difference so so how much is
unnatural then well well so it's not
only it's two important different
differences here first we're causing
it and the rate at which is happening is
a 100 times faster then nature would
make it happen Okay so we have had what
we call Modern civilization agriculture
for 11 12,000 years and we've been in a
relatively stable climate over that time
that allows you to say oh I can now rely
on where my food is coming from because
I have crops well let me Pitch tent here
and I might want to trade these crops or
I just invented a city well how am I
going to move the crops I need have to
be a city on a on a Water's Edge be it a
river a lake an ocean because that
enables irrigation it enables
Transportation it enables um uh all the
things that feed
civilizations uh functioning are are
improved when the city is on the water's
edge okay most of the great cities of
the world are on the water's edge yeah
okay just add them up it's all there so
watch what's happening we are warming
the Earth there's a huge Glacier on
Antarctica and another Glacier in well
they're multiple glaciers but Antarctica
is covered in ice Greenland is covered
in ice
okay those ice sheets are currently
melting if they melt
entirely the sea level will rise in the
world and will come up to the left elbow
of the Statue of Liberty the arm that's
holding the document most of the United
States that would flood all the coastal
cities of the
world so no we're not going to go
extinct from climate change just change
it will it will completely rewrite and
setback CI civilization thousands of
years it seems like that's something
that's happened over and over again like
for instance I went to Egypt and the
Nile itself is much different like the
the Nile met the temples there they
literally have like water ramps to get
up to the temple and and you know
there's even theory that water was used
in the Great Pyramid as a sort of
hydroelectric some kind of energy source
um but anyway the the Nile was much
higher so what
happened well uh so I don't know about
the volume flow of the Nile uh the Nile
is a huge Basin draining you know Nile
is one of the largest rivers in not as
big as the Amazon but it's big and and
the the catch Basin that draws the water
from the tributaries to the main river
to to the to the sea in which it empties
is is uh there's a there's a lot going
on there but I can tell you that since
we are change the reason why it's called
climate change a part of which is global
warming climate change redistributes
where the rain has been and where the
droughts have been yeah yeah if there's
some desert that's a desert and no one
lives there because it never rained and
now it starts raining becomes an oasis
you that could be that you can move
there perhaps but other places where it
had been raining and you built all these
crops and now it stops raining or it not
only stops raining it gets dry and then
you have wildfires this is the kind of
things that completely disrupts
civilization we might have lived on
Antarctica and had a j yes in fact
there's evidence on Antarctica that
there I don't if it's tropical plants
but you there's there's fossilized
evidence so when the dinosaurs were
roaming the Earth it was a period of
very high Earth temperature so all
evidence shows that there were no ice
caps at all huh wow yeah so so yeah we
can go back to that time but like I said
we'll lose all our cities and we'll lose
entire countries in the South Pacific
whose elevation above sea level is a
meter at most something like that well
how much time do we have what what do we
have left when does our son say I'm done
with you right we we're on a time scale
right there's AIC calendar we're we will
run out of eventually in about five
billion years wow cool the sun will
expand so large that will engulf the
orbit of mercury it will engulf the
orbit of Venus and it'll come so close
to Earth that Sunrise would be this
thing that occupies half your horizon
good Lord imagine the bur out I mean
we'd be on fire by then oh sorry yeah I
left that out sorry before would just it
just go frizzy that I left that out my
bad you uh the oceans would come to a
rolling boil and evaporate into the
atmosphere then the atmosphere would
evaporate into space and we would become
this charred
Ember orbiting the rarified outer gases
of the
sun ultimately descending into
this
Cosmic
Crucible vaporizing the entire exist of
the earth so about we're about halfway
halfway
halfway we got plenty of time to have
some fun okay my last question is bungee
jump yes yeah exactly yeah you know we
should go bungee jump you should do it
gotta live a little right I watch I'll
watch I'm a good Watcher I'll watch okay
okay my last question is in your book
The there's a quote or a sentence that
says to the Explorers among our species
and anyone else with the audacity to to
pursue that which scares them so I want
to know what scares you oh you're
holding me to that quote okay well did
you write it yes well no it's it's a
collaborate it's co-written with my my
co-author Lindsay Walker who's a
nine-year uh a senior producer for my
podcast Star Talk and that book emanates
it's the DNA of the of the podcast is a
thread of Science pop culture and humor
and humor I know I know that's why it's
so good we learn that if you smile while
you're learning you you come back for
more and as an educator that's the that
I don't ask for any more than that so
you're a great educator for what scares
you I think what we meant by that which
scares you is not you know jump off this
cliff and come back no it's not it's
that's not it what scares people are the
unknowns there's the poet rer Maria Ry
who commented we should learn to to love
the questions
themselves the questions are the
unknowns there are people who fear
unknowns I'll tell you how they do it
you ready they'll say uh Dr Tyson what
was around before the Big Bang I said I
don't know there had to be some I don't
know no there must it must have been God
was God I I don't know so then they walk
away feeling good that God was there
because that is an answer to their
question yeah it filled the unknown that
they were walking around with but I'm
perfectly content walking around in
ignorance of discoveries yet to be made
which of course continues to grow as you
ask every question the bubble of
ignorance gets bigger correct yes and so
so the poetic way to say that is as the
area of your knowledge
grows so too does the perimeter of your
ignorance I love that you said that the
last time we spoke and did I oh yeah no
that's why I that's why I'm recalling it
because I I've repeated that so many
times to people because it's really it's
poetic and it's also so true and I think
the hope that I have is
that with ignorance comes education too
so if we have the ability to ask a
question in which you've also said that
you're not afraid of certain questions
you're afraid you don't even know the
right one to ask if we're able to
actually ask a certain question it to me
is indicative that we're going to get to
An Answer however there's some questions
that you do not know are completely
absurd for example suppose 200 years ago
I say I wonder what kind of cheese the
moon is made out of
okay so so I devis all these fancy
experiments this will test for camon
Bear this is for Brie this is for blue
cheese this is for cheddar and I send
experiments to the moon and they all
fail I wasn't asking the right question
Isaac Newton knew how to ask questions
in his book optics for the first time he
had a whole section at the end called
queries by the way Optics was unusual
because he wrote that in English whereas
all his other books were in Latin which
was the academic language you would
write in but anyhow you read the queries
oh my God one of them is I wonder if the
stars of the night sky are just like the
Sun but
just much farther away from us yeah yeah
I yeah you got that one Ike you got that
okay we'll give you that so he so that
shows just how deep a thinker he was
yeah and so I that's why I respect the
Curiosity in others when it manifest in
yourself oh well you're just the man for
the job for me so it's totally a
pleasure talking to you again thank you
so much you were I have to tell you like
when you came and I spoke we did the
interview in New York about four years
ago I was about to leave and my producer
said Neil can be here in 30 minutes and
I was like everybody shut
up and I sat down I had like 20 minutes
to think about like to get my head right
and like think of what I was going to
ask and try and get but literally I
could probably just say go and you could
just talk and I don't need to ask a
single question um but I was so grateful
that you came and that has since been
one of the most popular shows I've done
and it was like my 10th interview at
that point in time so oh yeah I'm I'm I
help out I I'm you know people say oh
come on my podcast because these famous
people were there I I don't care who was
just is your heart in the right place
are you a curious soul and then I'm
there so don't I did a I did some there
were two middle school kids in Canada
who started a science club and they had
this new podcast like inside the school
and they they wrote me this like hand
letter will I be on their podcast I said
sure oh that is just you just I mean
that is that is beyond well yeah and
then it made like headlines the next day
you know the middle schoolers bag a
famous astr physic and I I'm doing it
because they you know if someone has the
energy to go to do that and to write the
letter and put a stamp on it and it was
a physical letter wasn't email because
my email is not out there and so yeah I
got let's call these folks back and do
it so i' had forgotten you're right on
that day I had other commitments and I
didn't know if they would end in time
enough to do that interview but they did
and so I'm glad it worked out yeah yeah
well you're wonderful and thank you so
much for doing it again and um hopefully
we don't have to wait four years for the
next one but until then um keep writing
books so that you need to do these
interviews and everybody go get to
infinity and
beyond I'll see you
there where that is thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button